[Aplausos]
bueno muy buenos días como ya
mencionaron el tema de mi charla estos
primeros pasos en la ciencia y bueno
decidí ponerle así a esta charla debido
a que el mundo de la ciencia
generalmente es un tema muy intrincado
generalmente requiere años y años de
disciplina para poder avanzar en esto
pero yo considero que hemos desarrollado
una fórmula para que aquel estudiante
que desee encaminarse al mundo
científico pueda seguir estos primeros
pasos y que su recorrido a través de él
sea más fácil si partimos de la
definición de ciencia la ciencia pues
una definición muy simple es el conjunto
de conocimientos de una determinada rama
del saber humano en este auditorio
seguramente son encontrar estudiantes de
medicina de química de humanidades es
decir todas ellas son ciencias y este
método podría ser aplicable a cada uno
de ellos
bueno primero que nada me gustaría
empezar con una pequeña encuesta podrían
levantar la mano quien tiene 25 años o
menos por favor excelente quien tiene de
25 a 29 años muy bien pues cómo pueden
todos ustedes observar la gran mayoría
de los que levanto a la mano son
personas que tienen 25 años o menos y si
se fijan la imagen que está detrás de mí
pueden ver a cuatro doctores que bueno
ya al momento ya fallecieron pero en su
momento hicieron grandes aportaciones al
conocimiento científico y cuyos
descubrimientos siguen siendo válidos
hasta la fecha y siguen empleándose día
a día en el tratamiento de pacientes
bueno si ven sus caras la verdad es que
no resultaría difícil creer esto pero
qué pasaría si yo les dijera que así era
como se veían cuando realizaron estos
descubrimientos ellos tenían entre 21 y
25 años eran estudiantes de medicina y
digo medicina porque en mi campo
seguramente se realizó alguna búsqueda
de ingeniería o de alguna otra cosa
habrá casos muy similares entonces como
pueden observar en la historia de la
humanidad ha habido muchos casos en los
que
a corta edad han hecho descubrimientos y
han hecho aportaciones científicas que
han hecho un parteaguas a lo largo de la
historia universal y bueno vamos a
hablar un poquito más de esto bueno yo
soy casi traumatólogo soy soy estudiante
de posgrado aquí en el hospital
universitario y formo parte del sistema
nacional de investigadores al cual entré
hace algunos años la cuestión de todo
esto es cómo llegar a la meta de
comenzar a realizar ciencia desde
ahorita que estás tú sentado ahí que
eres estudiante de pregrado en alguna
facultad o inclusión en alguna
preparatoria cómo llegar a este punto
bueno yo hay formado cinco pasos para
todo esto considero que el 5 es un buen
número debido a que bueno son 5 es fácil
y 6 ya serían demasiados y bueno de
abajo para arriba es encontrar tu
motivación conseguir un guía hacerte un
experto en determinado tema trabajar en
equipo y rodearte de los mejores de tu
campo y ya al final cuando has alcanzado
cierto grado de expertise enseñarle o
transmitir tus conocimientos a alguien
más primero que nada tienes que
encontrar tu motivación es decir la raíz
por la cual la razón por la cual te vas
a encaminar al mundo de la investigación
científica todo lo que hacemos en el
fondo tiene
una motivación ya sea dinero ya sea
querer viajar ya sea conocer más a fin
de cuentas hay una razón para cada cosa
en el mundo de la ciencia pues existen
muchas razones generalmente que pasa que
tenemos que hacer una tesis y bueno casi
que es que por fuerza y de una manera un
poco frustrante nos acercamos a la
investigación científica a nuestro nivel
en otras ocasiones otros beneficios que
podría tener obviamente es el económico
es cierto que te da prestigio te permite
acceder a un mejor posgrado a un mejor
empleo en el futuro bueno todas estas
son motivaciones que al final de cuentas
tú puedes tener en desarrollar
investigación científica mi primer
trabajo la verdad es que no fue nada
glamoroso en esto de la investigación no
me encontraba en un laboratorio de alto
nivel como el que está observando la
imagen ni trabajando con un acelerador
de partículas más o menos era algo así
se me capacitó en el manejo de animales
de laboratorio ayudaba a otros
investigadores con sus proyectos
experimentales cuando era estudiante de
medicina y la verdad es que al principio
yo sentía que no estaba haciendo lo que
a mí me gustaba y es en este punto donde
muchas personas inclusive abandonan el
acercarse a la investigación científica
porque pues se imaginan ellos que van a
estar en el laboratorio trabajando con
animales y seccionando cadáveres o con
pacientes en el caso de la medicina y
pues frecuentemente esto no es así pero
la realidad es que si tú sigues
avanzando vas a empezar a realizar cosas
que te gustan y cuando íbamos a ver
ejemplos de todo esto probablemente el
paso más importante es conseguir a un
guía es aquella persona que respetas que
te asesora en cada paso del en este
camino de la ciencia
generalmente tú te puedes ver a futuro
como él no es una persona que admiras
mucho y bueno lo puede llamar de muchas
maneras un maestro un guía profesor un
asesor un gurú un sensei o un yo ahora
todo mundo tiene alguien la cabeza
cuando piensa en esto yo tuve la suerte
de encontrarlo a temprana edad y la
verdad es que una vez que lo encuentras
jamás jamás lo dejes ir porque es una
persona que pues te vas a sobrar mucho y
mucho de lo que logras al fin de cuentas
se debe a sus enseñanzas
hay que rodearse de los mejores
obviamente pues no vas a estar desde el
principio con
en mi caso con los mejores cirujanos del
mundo tienes que empezar en un ámbito
muy local posteriormente ir escalando un
ámbito nacional ámbito un ámbito
internacional en esta foto es una foto
tomada en glasgow escocia el año pasado
en el congreso de la sesión europea de
ortopedia y todos los doctores de la
primera fila son los que yo considero
los mejores traumatólogos de europa los
que estamos en la segunda los hombros de
nuestro modelo de europa pero también
estamos en la fotografía entonces es
importante que te rodees de los mejores
a fin de cuentas ya sea en la ingeniería
lo que tú te dediques pues está esa
persona que admiras que escribe los
libros que escribe los artículos de
revistas o que desarrolla técnicas
nuevas y lo ves como algo muy lejano yo
he tenido la oportunidad de en una
reunión que hubo en alemania el año
pasado con 40 ex premios nobel de
medicina desde los 80s hasta ahorita
puede convivir con ellos la verdad es
que yo había leído muchísimo desde los
libros de la primaria hasta la
preparatoria a cerca de muchos de esos
científicos y después cuando tratas con
ellos pues te das cuenta que son
personas ordinarias como nosotros no
desayuné con ellos platiqué con ellos
ellos me comentaban acerca cómo fue su
recorrido otra vez
la ciencia y algo que es muy curioso es
que generalmente todos nos topamos con
las mismas cosas no son personas de otro
mundo y estoy seguro que ustedes a lo
que se dediquen está esa persona que
está en el top de su rama pues podrían
conocerla algún día ustedes podrían ser
en mi caso eso ni dos ni dos grandes
maestros mi sensei este el doctor victor
que es el que me ha enseñado en
especialidad de operar todo esto
bueno el tercer paso es leer y aprender
dice un dicho que el 90% de la labor que
hace un investigador o un científico es
enfrenté su computadora leyendo
artículos y el 10 por ciento tal vez sea
en el laboratorio experimentando o
haciendo algo de investigación ya sea
básica o ya sea clínica
hay que ser un experto digo no es de la
noche a la mañana pero si lo dedicas
unas cuantas semanas unos cuantos meses
vas a agarrar mucha experiencia en esa
área este es el número mágico que es
10.000 la persona que venga al fondo de
la pantalla se llama mal con el actual y
el escribió un libro en el que
mencionaba que para poder tú convertirte
un experto en cualquier rama del
conocimiento o en cualquier técnica
necesitas al menos 10.000 horas de
práctica continua es decir que no no se
vale dos años y luego descanso dos y lo
agresivo tiene que ser algo que hagas
intensa siempre de manera regular al
menos 10.000 horas o lo que equivale más
o menos a 10 años entonces es importante
que sepamos que esto se trata de
constancia el trabajar formar parte de
un equipo en el mundo de la ciencia es
muy importante debido a que pues bueno
no somos todos lobos yo lo personal
trabajo con ingenieros trabajo con
investigadores del área básica o con
otras mismas ramas de la medicina
entonces el trabajar en equipo y formar
parte de un equipo es sumamente
importante ya sea tu nivel
compañeros en pregrado o postgrado o
formando parte del equipo de algún
investigador probablemente de mayor edad
bueno estoy en equipo stephon personas
con las que trabajo todo el tiempo somos
traumatólogos a fin de cuentas este y
bueno en general pasamos mucho tiempo
con ellos
trabajan comen juntos este pasa el
tiempo y bueno todos cambian a fin de
cuentas estos son mis compañeros de
generación en la residencia y bueno ya
han pasado cuatro años desde que
comenzamos este viaje y hemos aprendido
bastante obviamente no todo es color de
rosa cuando tú te deseas involucrar la
investigación científica te vas a topar
con muchas cosas lo primero que a mí me
pasó era el desconocimiento de cómo
realizar investigación cómo realizar un
protocolo científico cómo registrarlo
ante un comité de ética cómo preparar un
manuscrito y enviarlo a una casa editora
para que se publique es algo muy difícil
y si no tienes una persona que te está
asesorando y obviamente tú leyendo al
mismo tiempo va a ser sumamente
complicado pero a fin de cuentas todos
estos problemas son totalmente que se
pueden solucionar en el pasado era una
excusa el no tener acceso a la
investigación a los artículos de otra
gente porque a fin de cuentas cuando tú
realizas una investigación te basas en
investigaciones previas para poder
adquirir conocimiento hace muchísimos
años hace siglos cuando
existieron las primeras revistas médicas
muy buena la lograría un journal de
cirugía en eeuu y se publicaba una vez
cada tres meses y solamente se editaba
en físico y tenía que ser enviado a
todos los hospitales del país para que
los médicos se dieran cuenta lo que
estaban haciendo en el mundo donde
vivimos actualmente en esta en esta era
informática la información y los datos
están al alcance de todos nosotros
contamos con bases de datos muy grandes
internacionales en el que podemos
acceder a la información con unos
cuantos clics pues esto ha dejado de ser
una excusa y prácticamente ahora los
problemas son más de ámbito de
desconocimiento o que a veces pensamos
que va a ser muy difícil combinar las
labores de investigación científica con
nuestros estudios
hay que enseñar a otros una vez que se
ha adquirido cierto conocimiento resulta
importante que se lo transmita a alguien
más porque así como tú llegaste tocando
la puerta de un laboratorio a la puerta
de alguna aula de la oficina de algún
profesor va a llegar a alguien más y es
importante que en algún momento tú
transmites lo que he aprendido en meses
o años a alguien más
ella es fabiola es una compañera mía que
me fue asignada para yo en su momento
realizar una tutoría con ella y este fue
el momento en que se aprobó su primer
protocolo de investigación tiene 22 23
años y pues bueno su cara lo dice todo
de qué sirve todo esto no a fin de
cuentas estamos en méxico y aquí en
méxico papelito habla y cuando tú te
pares en una entrevista de trabajo te
van a decir bueno y por qué te voy a
escoger a ti y no a los otros 30 que
están allá afuera así que tienes tú que
no tengan los demás ya se ha demostrado
en estudios muy serios y habló
específicamente el ramo la medicina que
aquellos estudiantes que una vez que se
gradúan realizaron investigaciones
durante el año de pregrado generalmente
son mejores cirujanos mejores médicos
porque el hacer investigación científica
los capacitó en otras áreas y se ha
visto que eso se traduce en su éxito
profesional a futuro y solo lo digo yo
eso hay múltiples artículos publicados
en muchas revistas
obviamente puedes acceder a un mejor
empleo y todo lo que conlleva todo esto
pero fuera todo esto a fin de cuentas
pues puedes estar con muchas personas
viajar por el mundo aquí en escocia
recibir algún premio por ahí pero yo
creo que es todo más importante lo más
importante a mi parecer es que generan
relaciones con otros científicos jóvenes
de muchas partes del mundo en esta
fotografía hay algunos que ahora son mis
amigos de muchas nacionalidades de
polonia de españa eeuu con los que ahora
me encuentro trabajando sin estar
físicamente con ellos esto es lo que
llaman el networking entonces ellos
tienen un protocolo de investigación en
su país te invitan puede ser que tú
desarrolles una parte de la
investigación en méxico y luego se las
envía a fin de cuentas todo el
movimiento de datos
y fuera de eso se centran a una amistad
bastante importante y tienes a donde
llegar siempre que vayas a visitar otro
país o sea
tiene que pagar hotel
pongo pongo esta imagen porque en el
2015 cuando voy a el premio nacional de
la juventud pues me topo con estas caras
que están viendo y eso todos son jóvenes
mexicanos menores de 29 años y escuché
la historia cada uno de ellos y me quedé
sorprendido porque a veces llega uno con
una mentalidad un poco negativa de que
no todo está mal y no se puede mejorar y
después no pude escuchar todo lo que
ellos hacían a edades ya había gente ahí
de 15 y 6 años la mayoría entre 20 y 30
por estar haciendo cosas muy buenas no
sólo en el ámbito de la ciencia sino
también en el ámbito social en el ámbito
deportivo o de tradiciones mexicanas
como puede observar ahí en la imagen es
decir gente en todo méxico y en todas
partes trabajando por hacer las cosas
bien y esto a lo mejor yo sí tenía una
actitud un poco negativa y a raíz de
todo esto grande que mi visión ha
cambiado bastante no importa qué camino
tome si estás estudiando ingeniería
medicina ciencias humanidades música a
fin de cuentas creo que estos pasos
pueden ser aplicables para cada cosa no
son excluyentes no porque decía hacer
investigación vas a dejar de practicar
tu ámbito la cirugía en mi caso
y muy importante enseñar a los demás
como ya lo dije bueno me gustaría
terminar con dos frases esta primera es
una locución latina pero esperad astra
es a través del esfuerzo hacia las
estrellas que eso es a donde tú te
planteas llegar
y bueno a fin de cuentas aquí les dejo
mi correo por si alguien por ahí me
quiere mandó un correo y tiene algún
interés en investigación y la segunda
frase que es de nikola tesla dice así el
presente es de ustedes pero el futuro
por el que tanto trabajado me pertenece
a mí muchas gracias
[Aplausos]